so today I'm gonna try and make flappy
bird and if you remember it was a really
really popular game about four or five
years ago and it's an incredibly simple
game the objective here is essentially
to navigate your bird between the
obstacles so you've got these pipes
coming in from the right and you're
gonna try and fly through them and
you're just gonna rack up as high a
score as possible the game doesn't
really end until you hit a pipe so
conceivably it could never end because
the game is simple you don't actually
have a lot of choices in what you can do
there's gravity that's constantly
pulling you down and you get the option
to apply an impulse or to fly up
whenever you tap at least when you're
playing on the phone so the game is
basically a treadmill in the sense that
the bird just moves to the right forever
and you have an option here when you
implement it you can either have the
bird move to the right or you can have
the world move to the left and have the
bird be stationary they achieved the
same thing and finally the game ends
whenever you touch anything so when you
fly through the pipes and you
accidentally touch one of them or you go
off-screen you go down to the ground or
something like that that's when the game
ends and you get your score so the the
whole point of the game is to fly
through the pipes without touching
anything and see how far you can make it
so now I'm just gonna go ahead and whip
up some assets we need a bird first of
all I'm gonna try and make it look like
the original flappy bird but my art
skills are just the worst so this is
about as close as I'm going to get and
if you can believe this took a few tries
the other thing that we're going to need
is a set of pipes now you could draw two
pipes and just put them all in one image
or you could just do one and make it so
really really tall and then flip it and
then there's another option which is you
could just draw the cap and the little
sliver underneath and then extend it in
code I'm just gonna take the easy way
out and I'm just gonna draw one really
really tall one and flip it in code but
if you wanted to save memory for example
you could you could just draw the sliver
in the cap and be and it would be fine
so before doing any coding at all I'm
just going to use the terminal to launch
pythons simple HTTP server if you're not
familiar with that it lets you serve
files locally to your browser which is
really cool because you'll be able to
use that to test and debug the game
directly without anything else so the
first thing that I'm gonna do is head
over to the phaser website and use one
of their examples this sort of gives me
a skeleton application that I can start
from what I want to do is customize it
for our purposes the next thing is I'm
gonna do is try to modify it
remove the bouncing logo in the star
field basically the junk the the cruft
that's in there and give it loading my
local assets instead of downloading
stuff afterwards the there's a bunch of
set up for phaser that I'm just gonna
organize a bit better
the overall goal here is to end up with
the basics of our game and get the sky
rendering so that we can move on to the
actual logic of the game flappy bird is
a pretty simple game so this
reorganization step isn't completely
necessary we could have also just used
the sample application as is the next
big thing is the bird getting the bird
up on the screen is really easy we
already drew the sky so getting the bird
done is no problem you just do the exact
same thing that you did to get the sky
in the screen the problem is that the
burden moves it has a velocity it has
gravity applied to it every frame and so
you need a couple things you need to
know when the user presses the key up so
you know when to apply the up impulse
and you also need the the time elapsed
since the last frame because you need to
know how to apply the gravity and
modifies its existing velocity so what
you'll notice here is that I don't
really know how to access the keyboard
right now a lot of programming is
figuring things out including searching
on Stack Overflow or searching the web
going through the API Docs and right now
I'm sort of desperately looking through
phasers docs for example code anything
that might work and trying it out
now that the bird is working I want to
move on to the pipes like I said earlier
we could have just drawn a single huge
asset with both set of pipes in there
and that would have worked just fine
although that would make collision
detection quite a bit harder since you'd
have to try and figure out the bounds of
each individual pipe given this large
one it's not the end of the world but
it's it's a little bit more complicated
what we'll do here is we'll create a
pipe pair object which will handle the
task of drawing both pipes one flipped
and you can see that instead of just
creating a single sprite in there I
create two of them but with the height
reversed and that'll have the effect of
flipping it upside down so whenever we
place this pipe pair now we'll do an
appropriate spacing between the two and
we'll have a pair of pipes that flappy
bird will have to navigate between once
we have the pipe pair object working
we'll throw a few into the world and
we'll space them out I'm going to space
them out at around 200 units or so to
start we'll tweak everything later like
none of this is going to be great right
now but eventually we'll come back and
figure out more reasonable numbers here
I just want to get sort of the basic
bones of the thing working
anyway the basics of the game is working
now you can control the bird you can
navigate between the pipes
there's no collision detection to speak
of but as you can see there's another
big problem you run out of pipes now
there's a really really easy solution to
that and what we're gonna do is we're
going to take whatever pipe falls off
the left side of the screen we're going
to move it to the right side of the
screen and that will give you an
infinite treadmill effect where you
never run out of pipes next let's make
the game end because honestly part of
what made flappy bird so much fun
originally was that it was frustratingly
difficult
now we don't have any collision
detection yet so I'm just going to put a
placeholder game over I'll display some
text and what will happen is you'll pass
through a few sets of pipes and as soon
as we recycle one the game will end so
there we have game over
so finally we're going to work on
collision detection now the easiest
thing to do here is to get the bounding
volume in this case the rectangle that's
the rectangle both around the bird and
each of the pipes in the world recall
back to that picture I drew at the start
what you want to do is check for an
overlap between the bird and the upper
and lower pipes now phaser has quite a
few options for intersection checks I'm
just going to use the docks and find out
how to get the Rex for the bird and the
pipes and then use this rectangle to
rectangle check to see if there's any
overlap between them if you find that
there is then game over so I'm just
going to add this intersects function to
the pipe pair object class what that'll
do is it'll check the intersection of
each bounding volume for both the bottom
and the top pipe because they have
separate bounding volumes and those
those will get checked against the birds
bounding volume and if there's any sort
of intersection there then we can safely
say that the game is over because the
bird is hit one of the pipes
now what you need to do is you need to
go and check the bird against every pipe
in the scene so we have the list of
pipes and this dot pipes so we're just
loop over it quickly and check the
intersection between the bird and all of
the pipes once you've gone and out of
this the game or at least the core
functionality is done all the basic
pieces are there and working for the
most part you've got loading and you've
got images drawing on the screen you've
got input and control over the bird and
you've got collision detection which
tells you when the game is over there's
more work to do before you can really
call this game complete I'll go ahead
and add some polish like getting the
bird to rotate based on whether it's
flying or falling I'll also need to go
back and add a score so when you pass a
pipe we need to keep track of that and
display it on the screen and somewhere
I'll also need to go back and fiddle a
bit with how fast the bird flies and
Falls like trying to make that feel a
bit better and I'm sure there's many
many bugs to fix
so here it is after going back and
cleaning up a bit it's not perfect but
it works the first thing I did was I
made it go fullscreen which looks a bit
nicer when you're playing I also added a
score to the top left so you can see
just here we go there so you can see
that as I passed the pipe the score went
up you can also go ahead and add
something like sound effects you could
you could do a lot of things at this
point but I'm going to stop here anyway
that's it for flappy bird I'll post the
code online if anybody wants to play
with it and if you enjoyed the video or
have any ideas for what to code next let
me know in the comments below thanks for
watching